it's a great honor for me to be invited
to this talk series
so yeah actually I took several courses
in this Auditorium and it feels pretty
different by standing on the other side
of the auditarium
okay so today I'm going to talk about
adaptable robotic manipulation using
tactile sensors
I want to start with this question why
are robots not around us
we all know that we have robots in our
lab and in the factories but we don't
see Many Robots in our daily lives
it is not just because we don't need
them
we definitely need some robots in the
labor intensive sectors such as kitchen
Healthcare and e-commerce pipelines
including packaging and delivery
so why don't we see robots in this area
the one reason is that they are all
contact Rich environments
unfortunately robots
do not handle the contact events well
so for example in this simple pick and
place operation robots do not handle the
objects that are slipping away
and also robots having hard time dealing
with contacts on multiple locations for
example on the box that is holding and
also the contacts on its body
so as you saw in the video contact
adaptive control is challenging because
contact properties such as friction
coefficients and the inertia of the
object is are often unknown
and contact conditions are changing
continuously and discontinuously
and also context can be made on multiple
locations
because of this uncertain and
unpredictable nature of the contact
then we need some tactile sensors to
achieve those contact adaptive control
for this reason many researchers have
developed tactile sensors from 80s and
now we have some commercially available
tactile sensors in the market and still
it is an active research area
despite these developments we don't see
Many Robots equipped with these tactile
sensors that much
so the one reason is that tactile sensor
is difficult to be generalizable
because robots have different Hardwares
and different tasks
and different contact physics
therefore each robot application
requires a unique type of form factor
and functionality of the tactile sensor
that's why I believe the research of the
tactile sensor development should be
combined with the research of the
robotic application
so that sets my research vision of
adaptable robotic control using tactile
sensing
in my new position at UC Santa Cruz I'm
planning to work on the neural tactile
sensing scheme that enables the
adaptable
dexterous manipulation and reactive
whole body manipulation
from this robotic system I believe we
can achieve the responsive collaborating
robot that can work with us and work
each other by making context together
even on our bodies
for this Vision I've
researched uh tactile sensors in during
my PhD and the postdoc
so I developed tactile sensors for
legged robots and developed tactile
sensors for the gecko adhesive grippers
and sleep sensors for the industrial
gripper and some stretchable sensing
array
and tactile sensing for the suction cup
gripper
today I'm gonna focus on presenting
these two research projects
so first I'm gonna talk about the
in-hand manipulation using multimodal
sleep sensing oh and then I'll explain
the haptic exploration and grid
monitoring of the suction cup gripper
and lastly I'll wrap this talk by giving
you some remarks on my future works
so first in hand manipulation using
multimodal sleep sensing
so yeah so now we have commercially
available anthropomorphic robotic hands
that shows phenomenal dexterity
however do we always need this High
degree of Freedom robotic hands to
achieve such dexterity
researchers have shown extrinsic
dexterity that utilize the contact
forces and gravity as an additional
degree of freedom
in this control they use a lot of linear
sleep and rotational sleep to do such a
dexterous maniflation
when they plant this control they use a
lot of analysis on the limit surface and
the friction cone which assumes a known
friction coefficient and the inertial
information which are not always the
case in the practical application
so this sets my research goal of this
project to adaptively manipulate unknown
objects with extrinsic dexterity using
sliding contacts
to achieve this extrinsic dexterity I
think we should have some tactile
sensors that resembles our human
mechanoreceptors so we have four types
of tactile mechan receptors for static
pressure and also the dynamic response
that is induced by the contact events
and the sleep
sleep of the object
from this inspiration many researchers
have developed multimodal tactile
sensors but most of the time they used
multiple transducers for each type of
model
and each type of modality
that makes the system somewhat complex
to process the signal and that's why
they are somewhat difficult to be
scalable
and also as we saw in the previous video
we want to use the linear and rotational
slip and the tactile sensor is desirable
to differentiate those two sleep modes
however in the previous Works they only
trained on small set of objects which
may not be generalizable
and also the gel side sensor can do such
differentiation but they may need some
surface features to track
so this sets my
sensor design goal so the first one is
to design a compact multimodal sensor
using single transducer
and the second goal is to monitor the
linear and rotational sleep in more
generalizable manner
so this is my solution the nib array
sensor so I'll explain the working
principle and the application of it the
in-hand pivoting manipulation in the
following slides
first the working principle
so my sensor is a capacitive type which
consists of the silicone rubber nip and
grounded conductive Fabric and the
bottom PCB layer
under each nib we have four directional
electrodes and we measure the
capacitance between these electrodes and
the grounded conductive fabric
so when the nib is under normal pressure
then all four capacitance will increase
simultaneously
and when it's when it is under Shear
Force then we'll see a differential and
directional capacitance change
and when the nib vibrates then we can
see those vibration by looking at the
frequency response of the capacitance
the last one is particularly useful to
estimate the Sleep Direction
because the slip will induce the sticks
will induce the stick and slip motion
that vibrates the nib
so by looking at the direction of the
capacitance vibration we can estimate
where the object is sliding
and there's one more secret about this
sensor which is about the internal
routing
so we have 36 nibs and that means we
have
144 electrodes under the layer
to reduce the number of wiring we group
them into three by three area and in
each group we connected the electrodes
on the same side all together
so that means we only need to connect
the 36 wires or 36 channels to the
microcontroller to measure the
capacitance
so to
to measure each individual capacitance
level we can connect one channel at a
time to the capacitance sensing module
however Nothing Stops us from connecting
multiple channels at the same time
and in this architecture
switching sequence means means the
capacitance conversion and the
conversion takes finite number of time
so if we can reduce the number of
conversion by clustering multiple
electrodes then we can increase the
effective sampling rates
if you can have a sufficiently fast
sampling range then we can capture the
dynamic stimulus induced by the sliding
motion
so here here are the two examples of how
we can cluster the electrodes the one
for the linear sleep and the other is
for rotational sleep
so we chose this clustering patterns by
looking at the shear stress Fields
difference
okay so let's compare the two modes the
individual scanning mode and the fast
clustered modes so there's a trade-offs
in the spatial resolution and temporal
resolution
and by combining these two modes
together we can achieve the multi-modal
sensing by using single the same
transducers
so this is how we combine these two
modes in a sub sampling sequence
so for each sampling we have we get
eight numbers
two comes from the linear sliding and
two comes from the rotational sliding
and four comes from the subset of the
slow individual scanning mode
so by doing this sequence we can achieve
300 Hertz of fast clustered mode
sampling which is sufficient enough to
capture the vibration of the nib
okay so using this sensor we tested how
we can differentiate the linear sliding
and rotational sliding motion
when we take a look at the slow
individual nodes we can
see the shear force field patterns are
quite distinguishable
but more importantly
we can take a look at the frequency
response of each fast cluster nodes
and as we expected only the targeted
sleep
mode and so sleep motions activates and
are activated by each sleep nodes
okay so now we can
differentiate the linear and rotational
sleep
so we
move on to the application of in-hand
manipulation
so in this Con in this demo the control
goal is to lift an object from the table
to its upright position
so the first step is to make a gentle
content so here we assume that the
object could be delicate so we didn't
want to apply a large grass Force
so we use the the fast cluster node to
capture the contact events faster so we
can stop closing the gripper
and then we lift the object slowly and
increase their grasp Force to suppress
the linear sleep
so whenever we detect the linear slips
then we increment the grid Force
and then we lift the object so much
faster
while we rotate the object up to its
upright pose
so in this case we monitor the
rotational sliding modes mode and if
there is no rotational slip is detected
then we decrease
the grass Force but that rarely happened
in our test
and we can also check the upright
position of the object by looking at the
higher frequency bands
because
from the kinetic constraints the object
will rotate faster when it reaches to
the upright pose
so these faster rotational speed can be
captured by the high frequency band of
the response
all right then the last step is gently
release the object onto the table
so here this controller is sorely based
on the event detection of the slave so
you can so it works regardless of the
inertia and the
friction of the surface
so we test it on different weights and
different Center of mass and different
textures but in overall we could make
about 80 percent time
make it succeed
but I want to note that most of the
failure comes from the releasing phase
not the pivoting phase so if we apply
some more sophisticated releasing
mechanism then I believe the success
rate will boost up close to the 100
percent
okay so this was my first half of the
talk so do you have any question before
I move on yeah well it's just a strong
question oh when you think it's
regardless of service I am to wait uh
how about like the geometry like because
like four equal models anything like if
that's the contacts not from Walmart
does that change your life
sentencing patterns
yeah that's a great question and
definitely in my sensor because it has a
nibs so if it if we have a surface
textures that can vary
um as it rotates or slides then that
will actually
even vibrates the nibs more so I think
in that case it's more desirable than
the flat surface cases so it will work
better for us for my case I guess
okay then I'll move on
for my second half of the talk
So In This research I'm going to explain
about the haptic expiration and grip
monitoring of the suction cup gripper
so when we use the suction gripper
one of the challenge is how to plan the
right contact points to engage
so in the previous work of dexnet then
they use the depth camera to and then
they fit it into the model
to predict where is the best contact
points of the suction cup
but they use the vision and they assume
the surface is smooth
but in reality when we take a take a
photo with using the depth camera
then the reflective surface could be
distorted a lot and it may lose a fine
surface details because of the low
resolution
and another application of the suction
cup is the forceful Peak and place
motion
but in that control they assumed a known
inertia and freak and friction
coefficients which again may not be the
case in the Practical applications
so we may need some sensors for the
suction gripper as well
so these are the
some solutions for the suction gripper
so obviously we can use some vacuum
pressure from the pump side but it it
only gives us binary like success and
failure information and also
we lose the useful information from the
local contact from the suction cup
well there is some indirect method of
measuring the deformation but still it
is not direct measure of the suction
seal
and I found one research that puts the
four sensors at the contact plate plane
but that means it will interfere the
suction seal formation
so to tackle this problem I propose this
smart suction cup that can match they
can directly measure the local contacts
without any interference
in the suction seal formation
so here we redesigned the single Bellows
suction cup
to make it have the internal four
chambers
and we connect pressure sensors to each
chamber
so the pressure sensor measures the
leakage flow through each chamber
and because they are placed remote
remotely from the suction seal then it
doesn't interfere any suction seal
formation
okay so we validate this design by using
some simulation
from cfd the computational fluid
dynamics
and we set two exemplary case
so one we call the linear leakage flow
and the other we call the horizontal
leakage flow
so the vertical leakage will mostly
happen when we misalign the suction cup
to the object
and the horizontal flow will happen when
we peel off from the surface
in the vertical leakage case most of the
leakage flow comes through the chamber
close to the leakage point
while the horizontal case the most of
the flow will go through the chamber
across the leakage point
this results in different vacuum
pressure distribution
so in the vertical case the lowest
vacuum pressure will
show in the chamber close to the leakage
Point while the horizontal case
the lowest pressure will happen across
the Chamber from the leakage points
okay so this is how my sense my smart
suction cup works and we applied
we applied it to do some haptic
exploration and grip monitoring
so here haptic exploration means that we
want to find the best contact location
by
just sliding over the surface without
detecting detaching the suction cup
so one obvious way that we can go is to
look at the pressure sensor level
and definitely this pressure the vacuum
pressure will be somewhat proportional
to the smoothness of the surface
however it results in pretty high vacuum
pressure which will engage on a Surface
which is which are not that ideal
so instead what we can do is we can
control the solenoid valve by pwm and we
can lower the duty cycle so the
resulting vacuum pressure becomes quite
low
but still this vacuum pressure Trends
Remains the Same
with respect to the smoothness of the
surface
and we when we take a look at the raw
pressure data then it oscillates from
the pwme
so we can do some Fourier transform to
see the magnitude of the frequency
response and these Trends Remains the
Same
okay so using this lowered vacuum
pressure we can even slide on the
surfaces
so in this example we start from the
left hand side and
because it was misaligned we see the
pressure distribution that was expected
from the vertical leakage flow case
but as we move along the surface then
the pressure distribution change and it
corresponds to the to the horizontal
leakage simulation
and as we move along the surface we can
keep track of the
the overall pressure response and then
we can finally find the smoothest
surface
by looking at the frequency response of
the overall Channel
okay that was the lateral searching but
we can also do some
surface alignments to find the surface
normal of the object
so in this case we tested on two
exemplary edges with sharper and more
wider corner
so in this case we can also take a look
at the pressure distribution from left
hand right hand side
and we can find the surface normal where
it should be aligned with the zero angle
we can also evaluate the surface normal
by looking at the pressure level at that
angle at that angle
so because it has an increase in the
pressure level Only The Wider case could
make the suction seal formation while
the other case failed to make a good
suction seal
okay so I presented two modes of the
exploration one with lateral search and
the other is a orientational search
so we can control this transfer the end
effector transformation matrix
Guided by the difference of the pressure
sensor reading
so we can simply make two difference
vector
the difference between left and right
hand side and also the difference from
top and bottom side
in the lateral search we can maintain
the orientation stay still
while we can move the center point of
the suction cup along the vector sum of
the two
and for the surface alignments we can
keep the translation part zero and we
can rotate the orientation
by
turning the suction cup along the vector
that is perpendicular to the vector sum
of the two difference
and also we can tune the intensity of
each happy expiration by setting the
weight value W to our increments
so so basically we have some control
over the weight value to choose what
motion we want to do
so when we choose the weight value 0
then it only search laterally
by maintaining the orientation stay
still and when we have weight wave value
0.5 then we have both lateral and
orientational search
and for weight value one then we only
change the orientation
okay so we tested this haptic
exploration control
to see if it can improve the existing GQ
CNN so this is my favorite the 3D
printed objects which is pretty
challenging because it has a fine
details which cannot be easily captured
from the adapt image
so we used the GQ CNN which is which is
the model used in the daxnet
well they call it grasp quality
convolutional neural net so we
downloaded the pre-trained GQ CNN and
fit in our new depth image and it
predicts where the contact points should
be and what's the confidence of that
point
and from that point we applied some
haptic exploration to see if we can make
the controller succeed
and I also want to note that we are
using the pre-trained model that was
trained from the different robotic arm
and different types of depth image and
also different suction cup
okay so here we tested on 10 potential
points that was predicted from the GQ
CNN but using the initial contact we
could only make it succeed by 20 percent
success rate
but when we apply our adaptive grasping
with the fixed weight of 0.5 then we can
ramp up the success rate by 70 percent
and also we test it on this pretty
challenging objects
and we tried 32 points that were
predicted from the gtcnn and only 56
percent were succeed at the first time
but by adding our adaptive motion we
could make it like 91 of the case to be
succeed
to be successful
so here we tested on the weight values
of five different values
and if any of them succeed we marked as
a success
so the remaining question for us is how
we can predict the weight values from
the given tactile information and we are
still we are currently working hard to
get a pretty good classifier so in my
preliminary test there was only like 70
percent accuracy so we are working on
improving those accuracy rate
okay so that was about the haptic
expiration and we can also do some grid
monitoring while we are while we are
manipulating the suction cup in a
forceful manner
so in this case we want to measure the
ground tooth contact of the suction cup
so we set the ftir frustrated total
internal reflection setups
and by taking a video from the bottom of
the acrylic plates we can capture the
ground truth of the suction seal
formation
so as you can see in this uh
pla then the pressure distribution
at the point where it
where it is about to leave the surface
it is pretty corresponds to the
horizontal leakage case simulation
however
this suction cup is under high
deformation and sometimes the frequency
I mean the the pressure distribution
is can be pretty complex
so we rather go into the data driven
approach to estimate the contact state
of the suction cup
so here we track the center of it and
then we label each quadrants
by looking at the weakest Point around
the suction seal ring
and we used the lstm network to predict
the context State label of each quadrant
so we designed the lstm to predict the
context state of the 30 milliseconds
future by using the data history
from
from the start yeah
so here we used two types of tech uh
sensor reading one from my pressure
sensor reading and the other comes from
the force torque sensor on the wrist
so here we compare the break quadrants
accuracy meaning that
whether the model can predict the
points when the contact label goes below
the threshold and we set these
thresholds by looking at the catastropic
failure
of the suction seal
so in the results we could improve the
accuracy of the prediction
about like 10 to 15 percent
by using the vacuum pressure sensors
and also we could see the break time
prediction accuracy and the result shows
that we can estimate the
failure
50 milliseconds before it actually
happens
so that means we still have some 50
millisecond window to respond to prevent
the impending uh suction cup failure
so that sets my research goal in the
near future so I'll I'll keep working on
the the Sleep sensor and the vacuum and
the smart suction cup
to work on the bean picking scenario and
also the fast pick and place operation
and we want to
put some adaptable robotic control to
prevent
the sleeping or failing objects
and I I would also want to work on the
neuromorphic signal processing of the
tactile sensors which will enable
processing the large array of tactile
sensors pretty efficiently
so therefore we can make some tactile
skins not just for the fingertip but
also for the for the other part of the
robot body
by using such a tactile skins I believe
that we can achieve some whole body
manipulation that utilize the context
from not only from the hand but also
from the arm and torso
and we can also do some social touch
and collaborative robots that can
communicate each other by using the
haptic cues
so I started with this talk by
asking the question why are robots not
around us and I believe from my research
robots will be around us
pretty soon
yeah I will I want to thanks I I want to
give my
uh
yeah acknowledgments on my previous
advisors and collaborator and co-authors
and funding sources and
I'm happy to take any questions
foreign
thank you for such a nice talk
um
when you were talking about the suction
gripper I I noticed that
um it seems like the the response to uh
like an a horizontal flow from one side
is maybe similar to Vertical flow on the
opposite side did you do any work to try
to distinguish like what's happening
exactly uh like if you have a signal
that's lower pressure in one side can
you distinguish if that's vertical flow
on the same side or like leakage flow on
the opposite side
Ah that's a great question and actually
that's why we wanted to go into the data
driven approach so as you said it could
be either from the vertical flow on the
other side or the horizontal flow from
the opposite side so yeah so that's a I
guess that's
not deterministic problem so we want to
throw some data from the text from the
pressure value and also from the force
torque sensors to estimate the right
leakage point from there yeah
I'll ask a very general what do you
think is the biggest kind of I mean you
talked about this this Vision at the
very beginning of having contact being
able to sense contact everywhere uh
being important for future interaction
with robots in different scenarios what
do you think is the biggest physical or
the biggest technical challenge at this
stage right so
so the biggest challenge is the wiring
and the processing of the tactile arrays
so
um
well we can put many tactile sensor
units all over the place but the
remaining question is how we're gonna
process them so
so in our approach I I guess the current
approach is more like the central
processor will query
the the tactile sensing information
every time but in our body system
actually the tactile sensors tells the
central processor whenever they have
some stimulus
so I guess we should shift those
processing Paradigm more like our
human nerve system
by doing that I guess we can have
multiple arrays all over the place and
easily process those information
efficiently
you mentioned wiring should we go to
wireless
uh well that's that's one
way to go but also then there's a power
issue and yeah and so on and so on so
yeah
hi uh hi thanks for the talk
um we had another researcher coming a
few weeks ago talking about the optic
optic based uh tactile sensor yeah uh
what's your view on that and how is that
different uh from the nip that you're
building yeah so it should be about like
gel sites type sensors so I I really
like it it gives a lot of fine details
of the contacts
uh well but when we think about our body
we don't have eyes all over the place
but we only have eyes on here and all
the others are the tactile sensors so
maybe uh well especially when we think
of expanding the sensing array all of
the surface then Optical approach may be
providing too much information than
necessary then it is necessary so I
believe there is a potential that we can
still have not Optical solutions for uh
getting a useful tactile information